this is a production of Cornell
University okay so I think it's a little
after 11:00 so we are going to get
started this is the organic no-till
session so I hope everyone's having a
good time and enjoying what you've seen
so far but we're going to be talking
about organic no-till I'm gonna tell you
about my experiences and then we also
have some farmers who have been
practicing organic no-till for several
years now so just to start off how many
people have have worked with organic
no-till before a couple people okay yeah
so maybe half of you or so so this is a
different type of cropping system okay
I'm going to start off talking about
some of the the benefits here and then I
wanted to talk to you about sort of my
understanding of the systems of the
system to the at this point you know
we've had some challenges over the past
several years and I think there's like
great potential with organic no-till but
it takes a little bit of additional
management and a little forethought with
this so in terms of the benefits as you
can imagine having residue like this
like we're talking about with the soil
health session that could be really
beneficial for a number of reasons
certainly to protect against soil
erosion alright in the past year we've
seen quite a bit of a increase in the
extreme rainfall events you know five
inches of rain and within an hour you
know a farmer just down the road
experienced that a couple years ago a
lot of soil erosion there so having this
mulch there can certainly help with that
we can improve soil health improve water
infiltration and another big thing here
is reducing labor and fuel requirements
okay so in the past I've always kind of
assumed that there are the soil health
benefits you know I figured an you know
we can measure this but you know there's
this assumption that they will be there
and I was more focused on this you know
thinking that organic farmers they do a
lot of cultivation and if they can get
away from that cultivation that interval
tuition that they typically do in
soybean and rely on mulch then that
would be really beneficial for them so
so this is a photograph from down at
Penn State and we're happy to have Bill
Kern and Mary Barbra check in the room
who have worked in this system down at
Penn State and with organic rotational
no-till and I think it's important to
just recognize what we're talking about
here so typical organic management
starts with you know some moldboard
plowing most of the time some blind
cultivation either time weeding or
rotary hoeing and then in multiple
passes within a row cultivation and what
we're trying to do with this organic
no-till system is to reduce this
basically eliminate this and substitute
it with this system where we're rolling
down this cover crop and then no-till
planting crops like corn and soybean
behind it I'll just tell you right right
now that most of the presentation will
focus on soybean organic no tell soybean
we have done some work in organic
no-till corn it has not been successful
as successful we've yea experienced it
quite a bit of problems certainly in New
York it's even more challenging but
where we do see consistent success is
with organic no-till soybean in two
rolled cereal rye or rolled triticale
okay so here are some numbers from a
modeling exercise that we did looking at
a corn soybean wheat rotation and
comparing traditional tilled organic to
this organic no-till system and in this
comparison both the corn and the soybean
were no-till planted okay that was the
assumption that we were making there in
the model and compared to this with the
traditional tillage and we when we
compared to traditional tillage basis
man and management we see 27 percent
reduction in diesel fuel 31 percent
reduction in in labor okay and also some
other environmental benefits in terms of
reduced energy use and reduce greenhouse
gas emissions okay
so I'm going to be providing some of a
broad overview okay and you know I think
it's really important to think about
your cover
and consider your cover crop to be a
critical part of the system here
unlike other cropping systems where you
know your main focus is your cash crop
and you know if you're lucky and you
have some time then you put it in the
cash your cover crop after your your
cash crop is harvested you know this is
a bit different you know you really need
to be treating your cover crop like a
cash crop okay so what that means is
seeding early in the fall using good
seed so you can get a higher rate than
what you might normally do okay and so
these are some photographs from Klaus
Martin's farm here this is a when Jeff
Lieber graduate student in my lab was
doing some on-farm research with Cloths
looking at at barley and triticale and
rye and so this is classes tractor here
with a front-mounted roller okay and you
can see the different cover crops here
that were rolled down and now what we've
seen both down in Pennsylvania and up
here is that if you don't have the
timing right if you are not managing at
the correct time there's potential for
receding okay and this can be this can
be a problem in some situations maybe
not too much of a problem in others okay
so this is what this looks like so over
here this is done at Rock Springs in
Pennsylvania so this was a cereal rye
that was rolled too early and so
typically what we say is when you're
rolling it down you want to see pollen
okay so that's when you can consistently
kill it with a roller crimper
okay this cereal rye and it's so for
people that are allergic to cereal rye
you know that's can be really dangerous
and you know quite problematic but in
general you want your tractor covered in
pollen if you want to be doing it at if
you're doing it at the right time and so
this is why that was rolled too early
and bounced back and that rise going to
seed here this rye over here this was
rolled a little bit later and you can
see the effect of termination there okay
Clare keen it was a graduate student
with Bill Kern done it and Penn State
she just published a paper looking at
the effect of this this this bounce back
and this incomplete kill
and what can happen is if if this goes
to seed now and you can imagine that
there would be volunteer crops in the
future and so if you are following this
rotation following soybean with wheat
you know having that we consider that
rye contaminate your wheat can be a big
problem however if you're planting
triticale after this and you're
harvesting it for forage it may not be
such a big deal all right so really your
crop rotation kind of dictates how
important the the timing of that rolling
really is and so this the system it
requires a different approach so I
really want to emphasize this greater
attention to detail here advanced
planning and adaptive management so what
I mean by advanced planning when you're
thinking about doing this this organic
no-till soybeans system you really got a
plan ahead you got to be thinking about
when you're going to plant your cover
crop and so typically you need to be
ordering seed in July the year before
you are going to be planting your
soybean all right get your seed to the
ground get your ride growing or your
triticale and then adaptive management
you know that's something I think we
need to pay more attention to you know
it really requires everything to line up
in the system for it to work well I'm
totally convinced it can work well there
are a lot of benefits and you can get
high yields in the system but it takes
everything to line up properly alright
and if things don't line up ok so say
you're prevented from planting your
cereal rye and you don't get it in too
late or if there's a problem heavy
rainfall and you have or bad seed and
you don't have a good stand you need to
change your plans and not proceed with
this so it's good to know what these
thresholds are alright so know when to
you know do something different no one
to plow ok so that's really important
and then equipment you know for this
system it takes different equipment so
we're using no-till planters that are
heavy to have a culture up front to cut
through that residue and then get good
seed to soil contact
okay and then unlike you know
traditional tillage based management
there are some different pests that we
have to deal with okay perennial weeds
can be worse in the system okay
early emerging weeds such as common
ragweed that's our number one weed
problem in this cereal rye rolled cereal
ride no-till soybeans system and the the
common ragweed is a problem because it
actually emerges and before the cereal
rise rolled down the cereal rise at a
stage that like I said with the when
it's going into an thesis and you see
pollen where it's very easy to kill that
mechanically when you have a little rye
seedling or a little ragweed seedling in
that rye the roller crimper will go
right over top of it and it'll go right
through that mulch and so it's this
these early emerging weeds that are
emerging before the cereal rice rolled
down that are problematic we also have a
number of different insect pests that
can be problematic
before coming to Cornell five years ago
I was working in Pennsylvania and it saw
problems with armyworm and black cutworm
and then just this past year working
with Janis dengue and a local farm in
Groton we saw a seed corn maggot and
that was the first time that I ever saw
a seed corn maggot but it is attracted
to this residue and so it's another
thing to watch out for when you're
thinking about organic rotational
no-till soybean okay just to point out
you know we do uh you know consider this
to be a rotational system here it's a
rotational no-till because of those
perennial weeds that I was mentioning if
if you're going to try to do continuous
organic no-till eventually you would
have perennial weeds that would come in
and tank the system and so we really
think that you need some level of
tillage at some point in the rotation of
course we want to minimize it okay let
that little bit of tillage once every
three years or so can be really
beneficial for managing those perennial
weeds
so crop selection a really important
factor here coming up from Pennsylvania
into New York I talked to a number of
people about organic no-till my plans to
start working with the system and I
would come across a lot of farmers that
said oh yeah you know I went down to
Burdell before I I saw their roller
crimper I've tried that up here and it
didn't work and what they would tell me
was that they would roll down rye and
no-till plant corn into it and I think
it's really important to recognize that
that's that's a bad approach I don't
think anyone that's working on organic
no-till it would ever recommend it that
and it's really because of nitrogen all
right
with soybean all right what we're trying
to do because soybean is a Legum right
it can fix its own nitrogen we really
want to make it work and there are
benefits with the Rye of with depleting
the soil nitrogen and so that has weed
suppression benefits and so that's
really the goal with with Rye to suck up
all of the nitrogen that's in the soil
and make that soybean more competitive
against weeds because the soybean can
fix its own nitrogen and if that
nitrogen is not there for the weeds it's
tied up in the Rye then that gives that
soybean a competitive advantage okay
now some people have talked about you
know trying to maximize your ride
biomass and adding nitrogen to do that
okay and I've I've shied away from that
we've are thinking now that maybe some
of these thresholds that have been
developed in terms of how much biomass
you need you know are not necessarily
appropriate for New York all right and
we'll talk a little bit about that later
but you know adding nitrogen to your
cover crops so then you can go plant a
soy bean to me it just doesn't make a
whole lot of sense and you you can run
into problems where your CEO or I can
lodge and you can also give those weeds
more of an advantage than they would
normally have okay but soybean in tirol
dry and if you are going to use corn
it's really important to go into a
legging cover crop
okay corn into R I typically fails maybe
non-organic farmers all right they can
put down starter fertilizer there's
certainly a lot of good planting green
farmers down in Pennsylvania that are
doing this corn into Rye but for organic
it's just really tough okay and so what
we say is that you know even with vetch
hairy vetch I I really like hairy vetch
I think it's a great cover crop there
are some problems with it in terms of it
becoming a weed certainly cost say that
he won't touch the stuff because he
grows a lot of small greens however if
you really want to do this system you
know with organic no-till corn you
should really be thinking about veg
okay and and not rye some mixtures of
hairy vetch and rye or hairy vetch and
triticale they might be beneficial in
terms of suppressing more weeds but
really you need to watch out that you
don't have too much of that small grain
in there or else you can have nitrogen
immobilization or nitrogen tie-up and it
really make your your corn crop suffer
okay so some of the other benefits with
the system as I was talking about
earlier with the extreme rain events in
the soil erosion we had a situation in
2015 or 2015 and and also this past year
where we had a very wet season in 2015
our June was particularly wet typically
we have four inches of rain at our
research farm we had double that in June
of 2015 and what was really amazing was
I was working with a graduate student
who was doing Jeff Lieber he was doing a
timing study of planting timing study
and he had four different termination
and planting dates and he was able to
nail every single one of those
termination and planting dates
throughout you know May and June even
with this wet weather because the Rye in
this system helped suck up that moisture
and allow us to access the field where
farmers that were working in tilled
brown or it did not have a cover crop
they were excluded from their field
field to just would bury their tractor
if they tried to go out there however we
were able to get out there and do it and
it worked really well so
here's some photographs comparing
tillage base management you know to the
organic no-till system here so you can
see the roll dry bare ground okay you
know this this erosion you this is this
area here this wasn't throughout the
whole entire field but we did see
patches of this certainly problematic
certainly don't want to see that didn't
see any of that in the organic no-till
roll dry system okay
here you can see that same area where
there's just a very poor drainage but no
problems with the organic no-till
soybean so in the past really thinking
about seeing these these observations
these effects with the cereal rye being
beneficial to deal with excessive rain
and so we always assumed that there was
um the these benefits and like I was
saying before I was more focused on the
labor and the energy use and just
recently started to get into looking at
the the soil health aspects of this and
trying to quantify the effects of soil
of this management system on soil health
and so I had another graduate student
Kiera Crowley and so she asked the
question you know compared to a no cover
crop control will integrating a cereal
rye cover crop prior to soybean improve
soil health weed suppression soybean
yield and profitability so those are the
metrics that she was looking at okay and
this was a research study that was done
just north of here about a half hour or
hour at the musgrave research farm and
and so I'll show you some of her results
first the treatments so there are four
different treatments that were compared
and so we were very interested in this
roll down system the organic no-till
soybeans system here but she wanted to
compare that to standard management you
know a lot of organic farmers they would
put out a rye cover crop but then plow
that down and incorporate it incorporate
that right cover crop that jointing so
that's you know one control
there are certainly there are other
farmers may be non organic farmers that
are not using any cover crop so we
wanted to also include a no cover crop
control and then more recently there
have been
there's been a lot of interest in
harvesting cover crops for forage so she
included a violent treatment here to
compare so there is four different
treatments with the Rye ledge harvested
at a boot stage you know just like you
can see in the photograph here so these
are the four different systems and so
let's just take a look at this which
system do you think had the best soil
health here and we'll try to make this a
little bit more interactive any any
ideas about that roll down system right
okay what about what system you think
had the greatest profitability eyelids
okay yeah good you're following along
okay so let me just show you the numbers
here you know we had two years that were
very different from one another all
right and 2015 it was very wet like you
know was saying 2016 it was a drought
year alright so this is the the average
line here alright that's the normal
accumulation of precipitation all right
and throughout the spring and in the
growing season again 2015 being very wet
alright and 2016 being very dry so this
is a really good comparison here looking
at these two years to see how these
different systems to perform in these
contrasting environments okay so we're
seeing right over crop biomass and I
apologize for the metric units but I
think you can just assume that this says
pounds per acre okay they're very
similar those units and so you can see
there was a difference in years we had a
greater cereal rye biomass in the spring
of 2016 and that was really related to
the seeding date here okay the first
year we didn't get our rock cover crop
in early as we as early as we would have
liked and so we were suffering a bit
with that lower biomass in these three
different systems but the difference
between these treatments you know that's
all related to the different timings of
the management so higher biomass in the
roll-down system because we were waiting
to an thesis until that until we would
terminate that cover crop
this was terminated a bit earlier the
rila and the plow down was terminated
just prior to jointing okay so that's
the rye biomass and biomass increase
with termination date right and so
here's a soil respiration data okay so
what we do see is that there's it looks
like there's a trend okay but when we
look at the statistics we see that there
is a difference all right between the
roll-down system and then no cover okay
these other treatments here where
intermediate
okay but this microbial respiration this
is one of the soil health indicators and
we were talking about earlier in the
soil health session and this just goes
to show you that there is some activity
some more microbial activity that's
happening in the soil and that that this
ride especially in the roll down system
having that mulch there is helping
promote those and maintain those
beneficial microorganisms okay
sorptivity this is a metric of water
infiltration so higher sorptivity
greater water infiltration okay and what
we're seeing here is compared to the the
no cover okay we see greater water
infiltration in the roll-down system
compared to the no cover where these
other two are intermediate okay and when
we do have these extreme rain events we
think that this is going to be really
important okay people that have the
rolled roll dry system and that have
that mulch there and protecting their
soil more water is going to go into the
soil less if it's going to go off and
take your soil with it okay
we'd buy a mess okay so these other
systems all right all using all using
mechanical cultivation so no cover plow
down mileage so we went through use
moldboard plow tillage did some blind
cultivation and then inter-row
cultivation standard management
practices for organic farmers and then
the no-till was obviously that mulch
that we were relying on for the weeds
but here you know you can see a lot more
weed biomass
in the roll down for anybody who knows
anything about weed biomass in these
units and has experience on organic
farms you would know that these levels
are extremely low okay
so 300 or 500 kilograms per hectare of
weed biomass that's that's really not a
whole lot of biomass at all
so we were quite happy even though the
spar is so much higher than these you're
still getting very good weed suppression
for an organic situation okay does that
make sense
right right exactly I mean this yeah
this is the type of weed suppression
that you might expect you know yeah a
herbicide based system right yeah yeah
and please as we go on and you'll feel
free to ask a question or shout out to
comment okay
so these are the treatments just prior
to harvest and this is 2015 we did one
other thing that I didn't tell you about
we actually interceded some hairy vetch
into these plots okay and that's just I
just want to explain what that green is
those aren't weeds that's interceded
hairy vetch I'm not going to spend too
much time talking about that but I think
there's a lot of potential with
interceding and actually using hairy
vetch in this particularly in this
organic no-till system to get a cover
crop established alright so this is the
the rough year here the drought year
okay so very good production you know
with the no cover with the plow down and
the Rye llege nice soybeans and then we
just had a mess over here the the
soybeans all right we planted them
no-till planted them into very very dry
conditions that seed sat there we didn't
get any rain afterwards you know for you
know no kind of measurable amount of
rain for a month or so and and those
soybeans just took they were stunted
they weren't growing as fast so the
growth rate was much slower and and our
yields were we're lower as you'll see
that is that is interceded hairy vetch
here yeah okay also some some weeds in
there as well
the vets wasn't counted in the weed
biomass sides that I was just showing
you okay we use a high clearance drill
interceder so we will see one tomorrow
if you go on the tour you know see one
in action rod Porter brought one it down
yeah or or right yeah bill Kearns talk
you know in the interceding session yeah
so say that again so you're seeing yeah
in the note tells in the mulch system
yeah you know we do see that you know we
seek a side-by-side our soybeans you
know getting yellow we're reaching
yellow leaf drop about a week or two
earlier than in the the no-till system
you know and so I'm not quite sure
what's going on there but then that is
pretty consistent I'd say yeah exactly
so it's something that we try to avoid
you know with the having that mulch
cover up all of the soil there okay so
let me just show you the yields so in 20
2015 again the I have this reference
line of 45 bushels per acre here but
soybean yields I'd say for for us you
know I under any conditions you know we
were happy with this in 2015 in 2016 we
were really disappointed and again it's
just because those soybeans had such a
rough start in that dry conditions in
that that dry soil and and rye that was
there that they were stunted and they
just never caught up and so you know I
think this is really important to
recognize here that there are challenges
before 2016 I was going around talking
about organic no-till soybean as a
solution to climate change you know all
the problems associated with climate
change and I thought okay well you know
in the Northeast our problems are too
much water in the spring and not enough
water midseason all right and under you
know the roll-down system that's where
it really shines you know we have too
much water in the spring the rice sucks
up that moisture okay and then having
that mulch there in midsummer that's
where it really conserves that soil
moisture and that's really beneficial
however this year really caught me by
surprise with this drought drought
conditions in the spring in June
you know so basically no no water in
2016 in June and and that you know
people talk about the the dangers of
cover crops in the West you know under
dry rain-fed conditions and you know I'd
never really thought that we've
experienced that here but here it is and
it was certainly a problem and something
to avoid okay
so summary of our results from Cara's
work so profitability as you expected it
was greatest in the Riley treatment and
if you can make use of that Riley sir
and then get a soybean and crop in
afterwards you know I think that's
really nice
there were trends in soil health and and
some of those other indicators that
we're looking at where it might be
better might just need more data to to
look at that to see if there are
actually differences more weeds in the
roll-down system lowest costs in the the
no cover
but lowest labor in the roll down okay
so i was thinking about you know the
messages that i want to convey to you
and thinking about these indicators and
thresholds that we have and i think it's
really important like i was saying to
know when to pull the plug or you know
if you're in a kenny rogers fan and you
you know that song the gambler you know
you know when to fold them okay you know
when to hold them but you also need to
know when to fold them and i'd say if
you you know this will prevent a lot of
problems you know i think people come to
sessions like this and hear about
organic no-till to get excited and they
go out and they try to do it on all
their land or in areas where maybe they
shouldn't try it and so what we're
suggesting is that people really avoid
weedy fields alright don't try to put
this in a field that you've consistently
had problems with you certainly want to
avoid field to have a lot of perennial
weeds in them i was talking with a
farmer you know i guess um well further
west of here
and he took CRP land i'm not sure if tom
tom was in the room but you took CRP
land planted rye and then did a no-till
soybean into it and it's really exciting
he was a very enthusiastic about it he
was um this is some of his first
experience with farming and
he wanted to do it this way but he had a
lot of perennial weeds and you could
imagine coming out of CRP land you know
this Conservation Reserve Program that
you just have a buildup of perennial
propagules and fortunately he was
successful I think he's getting a good
crop and he's got a nice price for his
beans but it could have been a lot
better if he would have went into a
field or tried to deal with those weeds
beforehand all right and then if you
will realize for one reason or another
that your cover crop is just not going
to do it you know it's not going to cut
it because it's too sparse or too thin
all right as you can see in this cover
crop okay these are weeds that's black
medic that's not not clover there that's
uh those are weeds and so if you're in a
situation like this you know I think
it's just really good to recognize and
to change plans adapt okay you know you
might have had the best intention to
doing some organic no-till but at this
point you should really be thinking
about either harvesting the Rye or
plowing it down or doing something
different mowing it all right because if
you try to roll it down and you try to
no-till plants hoping into it you're
going to have weed problems so again
thinking about this year and and the
these messages that I want to get across
if you're in a really dry situation like
we were in in 20 2016 all right so no no
rain for a couple weeks before before
termination but before when you would
normally plant and no rain in the
forecast and I say either wait for rain
or harvest for grain okay at that point
you know when you want to no-till plant
your your soybeans it may be too late to
harvest that that ri4 violets and for
forage all right at that point you might
just be better off harvesting it for
grain and then going in with a different
crop sorghum Sudan grass or something
else okay extra weight so this is um
from Penn State you know putting I think
bags of seed or fertilizer on the
planter to get some extra weight because
the the soil was so dry here and to get
that that Coulter into the ground and to
get better seed to soil contact and seed
placement okay
so fitting into a crop rotation this is
another issue that often comes up they
say okay well this sounds really good so
how do I fit this into my corn soybean
wheat rotation and in New York it's
really challenging to do that so we've
been thinking trying to put our heads
together working with our organic farmer
advisory board and trying to really
think about how how can you sneak in
some organic no-till into your crop
rotation or how can you redesign your
your rotation so that you can
accommodate this and so the problem is
that you really need to establish your
cereal rye early that's critical so
early September is ideal all right and
after corn green and it just doesn't
work you're not going to get the stand
that you need for that weed suppression
after corn green so you need to think
about doing something different you know
you can't have soybean after corn if you
want to do this and you're harvesting
your corn for grain and you're in the
north ok what people are thinking about
it what we're looking at is you know
following you know or some of the issues
with following organic no-till soybean
you know if you are going in with wheat
that's something that some people try to
do it's challenging even in a even in a
tilled organic system you know let alone
a system where the maturity is delayed
and you may be pushed back and your
harvest in a little bit later but just
in general it's challenging around here
to get your wheat in on time after
soybeans the other issue with that
cereal rye that residue there there can
be a bit of a green bridge and what
we've seen in some cases is if you go in
with wheat afterwards and you have a lot
of residue you can get you know diseases
like take all that can go in and be a
problem for your wheat crop so this
rotation of corn soybean wheat really
challenging there could be volunteer
rice seedlings like I was talking about
earlier you know if you have rye in your
wheat you know that can be problematic
especially if you're hoping to do
something if you're growing for a
food-grade market or something like that
and triticale you know might be a better
option ok
following soybean so you harvest your
soybean you have some time to put in
something you know but it might be too
late for for wheat
by triticale you can plan a little bit
later and the volunteer I see links in a
triticale forage crop are not going to
be as problematic okay so no big deal if
you have five volunteers in with your
triticale if you're harvesting it for
forage right okay so this is a rotation
that we're looking at in the organic
cropping systems experiment at the
Musgrave research farm and so we have
corn if you will up here at one o'clock
so I call this a rotation clock but it's
four years and one two three four start
with corn over here and intercede or not
but the next crop after that would be
sorghum Sudan grass again to give you
some time separate the corn and soybean
so you have some time to plant your
cereal rye on time okay around here
there are markets for circumcision grass
you know for forage a lot of people are
getting into double cropping a lot a lot
of dairies around here so there is a way
to utilize this and and then your cereal
rye going into soybean here you roll it
down and then triticale after triticale
harvested for forage you know if you fra
seed and seed some red clover into that
you go back to corn grain that way okay
so this is something that we're actively
looking at we don't have a lot of data
on this yet but we think that this is
going to be a lot better than trying to
cram things in with a corn soybean wheat
rotation and even though we're taking an
extra year growing forage crops we think
we're going to be better off in terms of
weed suppression and overall
profitability you know of course you
need to have a market for those crops
for that forage and a way to utilize
them but around here it's seems feasible
okay so how much time do I have and what
it where I'm really over okay okay so
I'm going to slow down here and I do
have some more more slides for the rest
of the time here it's going to be a bit
of a discussion we have a cost margin
she's going to talk for a bit about his
experiences and his thoughts on this
system we can always come back to some
of the slides I'm happy to talk about
this and if I'm thinking if cost brings
up something or if bill brings up
something and I have a slide that may be
how
fool to explain it I'll just throw it up
but close I'll turn it over to you and
yeah we'll take it from here
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu